desde Rusia hasta Estados Unidos en
Eslovaquia y Reino Unido el frío azotar
rápidamente en el hemisferio norte en
Estados Unidos se registraron las
primeras tormentas de nieve con lluvias
y vientos que provocaron el bloqueo de
caminos mientras que en Reino Unido los
cuerpos de agua se han congelado como es
el caso de la pequeña Venecia de Londres
hace bastante bastante frío en el río la
capa superior está congelada por lo que
no hay barcos navegando
en tanto que cuatro niños han quedado en
estado crítico luego de que se rompiera
el hielo de un lago y cayeran a la
helada
los informes de la escena y los vídeos
en las redes sociales indicaron que
varios niños estaban jugando en el hielo
de un lago y se habían caído a través
del hielo
nuestros equipos entraron al agua
nadaron hasta el primer niño y nuestros
bomberos capacitados rescataron a tres
niños más
En Croacia las lluvias torrenciales
provocaron desborde de ríos e
inundaciones de decenas de casas y
carreteras
misma situación que padecen los
ciudadanos de Bosnia
los invitados de mi casa acaban de irse
en un bote a través de mi patio
delantero evacuado por un barco dos
casas de madera más atrás permanecen
completamente sumergidas No podemos
llegar allí
el invierno no ha llegado oficialmente
pero Las bajas temperaturas ya golpean
con dureza y anticipan lo crudo que
serán los próximos meses